the lottery is literally a scam for poor  people think about it you're the  government and you want more money  you're already taxing rich people so you  can't tax them more and you can't tax  poor people unless you want rioting in  the streets so what do you do you create  the lottery you then go huge prizes in  front of poor people's faces  guilt-tripping them into thinking that  you can't win if you don't play when in  reality you're more likely to be killed  by a vending machine than winning the  lottery and if they do somehow win you  still tax their earnings and it worked  in some states governments get more  money from the lottery than they do from  Rich corporations and who plays the  lottery the most that's right poor  people instead of playing the lottery  get up to 12 free Stocks by opening an  account on Weeble in the pin comment